today's question comes from Jim and he
says my 37 year old sister still lives
at home with my recently widowed mother
lame
she is capable of living on her own but
chooses not to double lane
my parents have enabled her all of her
life
triple Lane we just learned that when my
mom passes they will give her the paid
for house is it wrong for my brother and
I who are completely self-sufficient to
feel resentful
well sure absolutely and I think I'd
call your parents on it yo you know you
not only screwed up her life but now
you've insulted your sons who went out
and and had you know we're productive
and and it's not going to help her by
the way because you know she's gonna
screw this up
this girl has serious problems and she
needs serious help 37 years old never
done anything in our life come on living
at home at your mother
seriously so sad so sad no I think I
think God will come to Jesus meeting
mama
and I probably do it was sister sitting
there yo you know that look right at her
and go you know she's a bomb
she's a bomb and you know because she is
a bomb and you know here's the thing
that's not calling people names it's
just an observation Dave you're bald
that that's not calling me a name it's
an observation I'm bald
it's a it's a reasonable observation it
occurs
your sister's a bum it's an observation
the good news is I can't die the bad
news is I can't fix being bald I could I
guess it got by a rug but um or do one
of those hair implant things wouldn't it
be gross for me to do that but anyway
the kind of screw up the whole brand now
but but your sister can choose to not be
a bomb these are behaviors she can
choose to have dignity and go into the
marketplace and perform which makes you
feel good about yourself really it does
your mom and dad are stealing that from
her they're stealing our dignity from
it's really sad so it is you know a lot
of the questions I get these days are
about families that are enabling a
family member
and you are not helping someone when you
say you're helping them you're lying
when you cause them to not be all that
God has set up for them to be you're not
helping them now if someone has a bad
time they got something wrong then
that's okay you can sit down you can
help somebody in but you're helping
someone who's not got a pattern of being
a bum so don't do that don't be a bum
don't didn't it yeah you know what you
want to do is say stop the bumming and
I'll help you and but you don't help
somebody while they're staying in there
crazy because then you're financing
crazy
which makes you crazy just a different
kind of crazy that's what your mom and
dad are doing they're classic enablers
very sad I take the book boundaries to
them let them all read it tell your
parents that you think this is wrong and
you're very very angry about it you're
right to be right to be wrong this is
the Dave Ramsey show hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show and so you have to
break the cycle you have to flip this
thing on its head and make it behave
you've got to get so fired up and wired
up that you're broke friends think
you've lost your mind
you